A light shines above a metal table, with a
chair positioned on either side.
This is the isolated, hermetically-sealed
interview chamber of Provisional Site 23.
Outside the room waits two shell-shocked human
Mobile Task Force members, another with invisible
ghost legs, three powerful cyborgs, and a
scientist from another dimension.
They’re all here to talk about one thing:
The nightmare that unfolded at Site 13, also
known as SCP - 1730.
Everyone thinks they know the story: A mysterious
site suddenly appears in Texas, seeming to
exactly match the blueprint for an abandoned
site that’s supposed to be in Nome, Alaska.
What started as a simple anomalous location
turned out to be an epic horror from another
dimension.
The task forces sent in by the Foundation
were either massacred or trapped inside, and
those who survived reported seeing unspeakable
carnage inside the base including a death
machine designed to destroy anomalies.
And that’s not all - as a result of the
mysterious Thresher machine, the entire location
had been transformed into a shifting, spatial
anomaly filled with creatures straight out
of a nightmare - from giant, telepathic leech
monsters, to huge, multi-limbed Demi Gods
that would eternally punish the site’s murderous
director, Elliot Emerson.
It was only through the combined might of
three different Mobile Task Forces - including
the legendary Samsara - and the sacrifice
of brave Captain Hollis that this cursed location
was finally flung into a different dimension,
neutralizing the threat it posed to our reality.
But for the SCP Foundation, the story doesn’t
end with neutralization - there’s still
plenty more questions that need answering.
That’s why, today, we’re going to tell
you what they found out after the neutralization
of SCP - 1730.
Not only will we discover what’s become
of the many people involved, we learn about
what happened in the last moments before the
neutralization took place.
And perhaps most importantly of all, for the
sake of our universe, we will find out how
Site 13 came into existence - and how Site
Director Emerson went down such a dark path.
It’s time to get some answers.
Welcome to the final part of the SCP - 1730
Saga, as we close the book on one of the most
deadly locations in the Foundation multiverse.
First to sit down in the interview chair was
Captain Ephram Ross, leader of Mobile Task
Force Apollo 3 also known as The Game Wardens.
He was a shaken man, looking far older than
his 35 years, his eyes heavy with the weight
of the horrors he’d seen.
He and his team were among the first to venture
into the bowels of Site 13 and witness the
atrocities that’d gone on down there like
the Body Pit, full of fleshy slurry, or the
countless containment chambers that marked
their occupants for vivisection and termination.
Captain Ross was haunted by the things that
had happened to his team under his watch such
as the anomalous transformation of Houston’s
legs and the nightmarish warping death of
Noah at the hands of a stretchy, reality-bending
anomaly.
He compared the state of chaos going on down
there to something like Jurassic Park, where
all hell had broken loose and the monsters
ruled.
He also remarked on the Olympia Containment
Cells, each the size of a football stadium,
capable of containing things far beyond the
scope of this universe’s SCP Foundation.
His interviewer was the hard-nosed Dr. Peter
Vincent, who thanked Captain Ross for his
contributions, and called in the next interview
subject: Agent Liam Ohalo, a Game Wardens
Task Force member working under Captain Ross.
He had a thousand yard stare, and even the
untrained observer could see that Agent Ohalo
had left some part of himself back in Site
13.
When Dr. Vincent attempted to interview him,
he mostly remained silent, only volunteering
one grim sentiment:
“We should’ve died in there.
This isn’t real.
We were supposed to die in there.”
Next to be interviewed was Captain Irantu
of Mobile Task Force Tau-5, aka Samsara.
His interviewer, Dr. Isha Saint Claire, questioned
him about the nature of the mission, and the
cybernetic soldier was even-keeled about the
matter.
He said that, in spite of regrettable losses
of life, he was still satisfied with the outcome
of the mission overall.
The high-value targets were rescued, the anomaly
was - for all intents and purposes - neutralized,
and the degree of loss was actually better
than their pre-mission predictions.
It seems that the weight of death doesn’t
weigh quite as heavily on those who will probably
never have to experience it, as the Samsara
team are capable of simply being rebooted
into new bodies if terminated in the field.
People like Captain Hollis weren’t as lucky.
Next, Agent Cotter Houston of the Game Wardens
was both interviewed and medically evaluated
by Dr. Ian Harris.
Agent Houston had his legs dematerialized
after he tripped into a rising tide of anomalous
liquids - which he described as looking like
a moving, physical computer glitch.
However, in spite of this, Agent Houston is
still able to stand and move of his own free
will.
It seemed to Dr. Harris that Houston’s legs
were somehow trapped between dimensions.
Houston told Dr. Harris that he didn’t experience
any kind of pain when his legs were removed,
but to this day, he occasionally feels something
furry brushing up against them.
Perhaps, wherever his legs are, they aren’t
alone...
Next, the stoic Agent Munru of Samsara was
interviewed by Captain Elliott O’Neil of
Mobile Task Force D-26, also known as Time
Cops.
Captain O’Neil had a bone to pick with Munru
- namely, that he’d allowed Captain Hollis
to run off and sacrifice her own life, despite
having a clear directive to prevent the human
task force members from endangering themselves
at any cost.
Munru deflected, claiming that when Hollis
separated from the group, he assumed that
she ran off with intentions that never included
her own demise.
O’Neil and the Foundation found this answer
unsatisfying, and decided to move on to their
next interview with Onru - the last person
with Captain Hollis before her death.
The interviewer, Dr. Darian Arnold, probed
the elite Samsara operative on why she turned
off her camera before she and Hollis reached
the Thresher - the machine that Hollis overloaded
to annihilate Site 13 from our dimension.
She gave a more compelling answer than Munru:
When she and Hollis entered a server room
on the way to the Thresher, they encountered
what may have been the ultimate cognitohazard:
It was a vision of a terrifying alternate
dimension with billions dead.
A poisoned star like the biblical wormwood
fell from the burning sky.
A Nightmare God, like the one torturing Elliot
Emerson, wandered among fields of crucified
people, covered in deadly, cognitohazardous
runes.
Just looking at it burned the SCRAMBLE technology
out of Munru’s eyes, and she turned off
her cameras to avoid potentially frying the
brains of mission control.
Hollis wasn’t so lucky.
The things she witnessed broke her sanity,
and when she finally overloaded the Thresher
machine, she was laughing and crying.
Finally, in perhaps the most enlightening
debriefing interview of them all, Site Director
Willam Vesterland interviewed Dr. Mohammed
Scott - The highest-ranking researcher of
Site 13, and confidant of the now-infamous
Director Elliot Emerson.
The question was simple: just what had happened
for Site 13 to become so messed up?
And Dr. Scott answered in detail, with a tale
of corruption, alternate realities, and the
perils of unchecked power.
In his home dimension, Site 13 was originally
created in Nome, Alaska to house the corpse
of a giant sea creature that beached itself
on the border of India and Bangladesh in 1964.
It became the largest and most secretive Foundation
containment facility in the latter half of
the 20th century.
However, disaster struck in 1994, when a Marxist
extremist used an anomaly to level the Willis
Tower in Chicago.
As a result, the Foundation lost a lot of
its funding and international support, leaving
it in dire financial straits.
Enter the true villain of the Site 13 story:
Paul Manafort.
If that name sounds familiar to you, it’s
because he was an associate of President Trump
in our universe who got into legal trouble
for shady international dealings.
However, in Dr. Scott’s universe, he was
a powerful staffer for President Bob Dole
- who in that reality had beaten Bill Clinton
in the 1996 Presidential Election.
Manafort was made the new Secretary General
of the Global Occult Coalition - The UN’s
answer to the SCP Foundation, and one of their
leading competitors, with an ethos geared
towards killing rather than containing anomalies.Manafort
and the GOC co-opted the struggling Foundation,
providing them with money in exchange for
control.
The Foundation had no choice but to accept
this deal with the devil.
Slowly, Manafort replaced the Foundation old
guard with toadies and loyalists.
The Ethics Committee and the O5 command were
dismantled.
Dissenters were dragged out of their offices
and shot point blank in the head, execution-style.
Site 13 had originally been directed by Dr.
Bright, but Bright was arrested and contained
under false pretences so Manafort could install
a new director: A mid-level researcher by
the name of Elliot Emerson.
Emerson is often painted as a sadistic monster
who took pleasure in torturing anomalies to
death and flushing them down the body pit.
The reality is both simpler and more grim:
Emerson, it turns out, was just an eager yes
man.
He was put into his position to follow Manafort’s
orders to a tee, and those orders were simple
- Kill.
In a perfect example of the banality of evil,
Director Emerson converted Site 13 into a
brutal slaughterhouse, just as his overlords
at the GOC had ordered him.
But things were quickly getting out of hand,
and one of the most vocal critics of the new
regime was one of Emerson’s old lovers,
one Dr. Vera Hadley, Assistant Director of
Anomalous Biology.
Dr. Hadley was disgusted by the inhuman acts
Emerson was carrying out and couldn’t stay
silent, and for this she faced horrific consequences.
Corrupt guards stripped her and beat her to
within an inch of her life in front of her
co-workers.
In that moment, she swore her revenge.
She sabotaged the containment procedures and
had the engineers rig the already unstable
Thresher device to overload.
As Emerson watched the anomalies break containment
he began to fear for his life - both from
the anomalies themselves, and from the punishments
of his superiors at the GOC.
Dr. Scott revealed that Emerson was no evil
mastermind.
He was a lapdog for the GOC.
A dirty coward, all the way to the very end.
And he was desperate.
He held Dr. Scott at gunpoint and ordered
him to activate the Thresher or die, and the
rest is history.
There would be no redemption for Dr. Scott’s
former friend, as Emerson ended up chained
to the rune-covered, platform head of a Nightmare
God for all eternity.
So ends the debriefing of the Site 13 survivors,
and closes the book on that terrible place
- for now, anyway.
The story of SCP - 1730 is anything but simple,
and there are so many angles from which this
dark tragedy of cruelty and corruption can
be approached.
And ultimately, it was all for the same two
things at the root of every evil: The desire
for money and power.
But the pursuit of these base desires can
lead to some truly nightmarish consequences,
and nobody knows this better than former Director
Elliot Emerson - who’ll be paying for these
sins until the end of time, and perhaps even
beyond.
Now go check out another epic tale from the
SCP Foundation, SCP-5000 - The Suit.